We're here with Harpinder Singh,
a partner at Innovation Endeavors, and
the CEO of Slice.
Thank you for joining us.
>> Thank you, Amir,
it's a pleasure to be here.
>> So
how did you become an entrepreneur?
>> So, my journey's a little bit
different from most other entrepreneurs.
I met my co-founders at
Stanford Business School back in 2000,
and we were working together on
a business plan before we graduated and
that idea did not pan out.
But we really enjoyed working
together as a team, so
we were essentially
a team before an idea.
And we all decided to commit six months,
we decided to say no to the jobs.
And we invested some of our own money,
and
went through a structured search
process for about six months.
We looked at a few different spaces,
several different ideas, and
our benchmark was can we get
excited about something ourselves?
And do we want to spend the next six or
seven years doing it?
So that's what we did,
we created a company called FiberTower.
It was a wireless infrastructure
company which we built and
sold after six or seven years.
And, we took some time off, and
the same thing came together.
And, we did the same exact process,
looked at a few different spaces,
few different ideas, and
created Slice out of it.
And the common theme was we,
at that time,
felt that wireless was growing a lot and
e-commerce receipts were growing, and
we felt that data would
be very valuable.
So, that's what we've
done two times now.
>> So how do I determine that my idea
is the right idea to
build a business around?
>> As an investor and as a founder,
the answer may be somewhat different.
As an investor,
I'm definitely trying to see is this
potentially a big market,
a high growth market?
Does it give you enough room for
exploration and for errors?
So, that's one thing that's important.
And then the second is do you have
some defensibility, at least for
a few years until you create room for
yourself.
And as a founder, there's a couple of
other factors that become important.
I mean, as a founder it's not
always clear from the beginning,
is it a big market,
is this like a mega-market, and so on?
So you generally want pick big markets,
but
you're picking problems that
you can relate to personally.
And, I like to pick problems that
have some kind of defensibility
around technology, or
around the data component.
So, you want to create
some barrier that the guy
across the street just
can't do over night.
>> So should an entrepreneur find a
small niche or think big from the start?
>> It depends on how you define niche.
Snapchat is niche, Instagram is niche,
but these are big companies.
I think there's couple of
different ways to think about it.
I have friends who have
acquired small companies,
$10 million revenue companies, and
grown them to $30, $50 million revenues,
and grown the EBITDAs, and they've
created a lot of shareholder value.
I think the traditional Silicon Valley
would look at that and say,
that's not big.
So if you're thinking technology,
if you're thinking Silicon Valley,
especially if you're thinking
about raising venture capital,
then I think the bar is different.
People are looking for
billion dollar plus outcomes.
And there, by definition,
you're looking for
big markets, ability to accumulate
large user bases and so on.
So it really depends on
what your strengths are.
Are you more of an operator
that wants to optimize?
Are you more of an innovator that
wants to sort of create magic and
have this thing that can just sort of
grow to be something unimaginable?
And there are trade-offs.
It depends on how much
capital do you want to raise.
It depends on what kind of employees
will you attract, how much ownership
will you retain, and, really, what is
the core competence of the business?
Is it design and product,
is it operations, is it sales?
So I think there is no
one answer to this.
People have created a lot
of shareholder value
from what might seem small
versus what seem like megahits.